Bobby?
Becca!
Hey! It's been a while. How you doin'?
How am I doing? The real question is how are you doing?
I'm fine! But let's talk about you. What's been going on?
So many things! You know, I've been so busy lately. It's crazy.
Busy with what?
Just so many projects up in the air right now for me. I'm just kinda waiting to see how they come through, y'know
Uh, it's great. I've been writing more, I've been hitting the gym, just focusing on stuff I care about.
Well good, you look great. I mean, you look the same as you did in college.
Yeah, well, you know me. I'm afraid of change.
You were interning at that tech company, right?
Yeah! I'm still there, Yea! Still doing the same thing!  Y'know, every day. Again.
And again. But, but I love it still. It's um, it's great so it's meaningful work and
It's awesome!
Are you still with uh..
Teddy?
N-no. We broke up. But it's for the best. It was mutual, so.
I'm sorry to hear that.
Ah well, don't be too sorry! It's not like I'm gonna sleep with ya just 'cause I'm single!
Oh, don't worry! I don't want to sleep with you either.
Y'know I like riding solo right now, y'know?
Cheers to that, my friend!
Do you want a family eventually?
Oh no, I had my tubes tied last year.